prêts à des années à ne pas savoir
écouter ça suffit la crise du logement
nous on l'a vu aux 4,6 et
les organismes communautaires et des
citoyens ont manifesté pour dénoncer la
crise du logement au québec
ces deux hommes vivent dans le même
immeuble résidentiel ils font face à une
augmentation de loyer importante des
champs 10 dollars par mois
d'augmentation j'ai dû prendre un avocat
qui nous coûte beaucoup d'argent les
autres locataires jackie chan
n'ayons pas beaucoup d'argent non plus
fait qu'ils peuvent pas se défendre
hausses de loyer éviction et pénurie de
logements abordables les locataires sont
attaqué sur tous les fronts dénonce le
regroupement des comités de logement la
crise du logement touche des villes
comme montréal québec mais touche aussi
également des villes où il ya moins de
ressources des plus petites villes selon
la schl le taux d'inoccupation sur le
marché locatif frôle les 0 % dans
certaines villes il est de 0,2 pour cent
à rimouski et de 0 8% à gaspé à montréal
le taux d'inoccupation est de 3% et il
est de 2,5 pour ça à québec la ministre
des affaires municipales et de
l'habitation andré la forêt reconnaît en
partie cette crise va être très prudent
ce n'est pas la grandeur du québec mais
de toute manière l'important c'est
d'être en mode solution est de rattraper
le retard du passé et on augmente
l'offre on est rendu à 8000 logements
livrés on ne premiers quinze mille
logements qu'on va financer la pénurie
de logements abordables a été exacerbée
par la pandémie et la hausse des coûts
de construction
ce que réclament les comités de logement
c'est un gel des loyers et un registre
public afin de réguler le prix des
logements ici par isabel rochât radio
canada montréal